well i remember we were drinking we were
drinking water a little paper cup we
were at this burrito place and you were
like
if uh if i could buy this cup for five
cents and sell it to you for seven cents
that's my passion
yeah
i feel like i can rule the world i
[Music]
episode the guest from episode 2 which
was one of the best episodes ever of
this podcast
and then it was taken down for a bit i
don't know what happened there was
something we got to take down make a
little edit
people started hitting me up
hey what happened to ramone's episode
that's how much people cared they wanted
to know that people were just keep
attracted to that episode still in the
library something happened some people
noticed which was amazing to me and now
you're twitter famous yeah
as of today well because of you and sam
yes because as of today because you and
sam retweeted me and i got like
almost 8 000 followers overnight i went
from 2 000 to 11 000 uh within 24 hours
so wow okay
well it's not just because we retweeted
i retweeted a lot of stuff you told a
great story uh i'm just actually gonna
i'm gonna find the hook here uh because
you did a good job did sam write this
for you uh or did you have him edit this
because this was so well done i felt
like you can't this can't be your first
thread and you started off this good on
your first thread how did that happen
no
well it's sam dripping off the whole uh
tweet so sam actually helped me
um okay this one would work this is the
concept this is a little bit like how
you format it then he gave a little bit
like i would start with this i will do
this and i will explain that uh then of
course i you know explained it and then
um so what's the difference
this looks great how would you have
started it normally and then i'll show
i'll read what what the end result was
what would you have normally said or
what do you remember what your v1 might
have been
yeah well like you you and i are friends
so you also know me personally sam too
is like typically i would not start off
with like i bought something for just
little as x
and now we're doing why uh i will not to
brag
yes and um but you know sam said like no
that's you need to do that
um and you know it's true as well right
so why not just uh explain it that
that's what people get people interested
um and you know now i think we have
seven thousand likes and
a bunch of thousands
here's what you're saying
you said two and a half years ago i
bought a dog ramp business for three
hundred thousand dollars already
interesting what the heck is the dollar
grant business
since then i've sold 35 million dollars
of dog ramps boom that's the the hook
right um yeah you know
this little thing turned into a big
thing and then the promise why you
should read this thread i'm going to
explain why i bought it how i scaled it
and why i bought a business versus
starting from scratch but first dog
ramps question mark and then that is and
then the little hand pointing down like
come read more that is
uh you didn't take my power writing
class but that is exactly what you would
have been my star student in this if you
had done this as the example because it
has all three elements right
so it has the what i call the frame i
bought it for 300k and i've sold 35
million so that's the wow factor why
should i pay attention to this and why
do i stop scrolling right so you have a
scroll stopping
number 35 million dollars of dog rams
you have a curiosity gap which is what
the heck is a dog ramp and how did this
guy do it
and then you have a promise which is i'm
going to tell you
a b and c
but first dog ramps which is like
you you give them a lightweight entry
way that they they have even if they
don't want to know how you bought it
while you scale it all the operational
stuff i do need to know what the heck
dog ramps what the heck and so uh
beautifully done and then you tell the
story and the story is kind of amazing
because people know that i
people know that i don't talk about what
my e-commerce business is but they know
that i have an ecommerce business what
they don't know is that it started
because we were hanging out in your
backyard and we were talking and the
whole time we're talking
uh your phone is just going
to ching it's like the i didn't even
know what this was it's the shopify
shopify's like notification sound and
um
you didn't even notice it because it's
always just normal to you your phone was
sitting on the table and i was like do
you need to get that like what is that
sound and you go oh sorry that's like
sales
and i was just like
you know people love this idea of make
money while you sleep like passive
income oh make money while you sleep
that is a sexy idea this was this is
even better it was like you were just
chilling and having fun and money was
just being made for you on the side and
just like a little cha-ching every five
minutes and it was literally in that
moment i was like i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna start an e-commerce business
because
i can't sit here and just let remote
have all the fun this is too good so you
inspired me to do it for sure
that's awesome yeah i had to turn off
that notification uh because it drove me
crazy eventually like uh cheating
teaching every time there's a cell uh
but it was fun in the beginning i was
really like almost like that uh you know
endorphin release each time
yeah
exactly um and if you're on youtube if
you're watching the youtube channel
which is just i don't know what is it
youtube.com
my first million i think or hustlecon
something like that just search my first
million on youtube you'll find it but
you can see the ramp behind ramone so
he's got the uh all the products behind
you so the company's called alpha paw
that's your thing so we're gonna talk
about
uh a couple different things i thought
it'd be fun to have you on your
substitute teacher for sam and like any
substitute teacher the class always has
more fun when the sub comes in uh so so
that's what we're going to do
i think we're going to talk about a
couple things i want to talk to you
about
kind of uh buying and selling buying
businesses rather than starting
businesses so how you do it and we'll go
through some examples maybe of what's
out there and then we'll jump back and
we'll dig into kind of like your story
so uh how the heck you got started but i
first want to give
the the
the people and myself really kind of a
crash course on
this process of buying businesses
because i was amazed when you told me
you bought this business for 300 000
and did you buy this off of flippa or
quiet light or where'd you had to buy
this this one
um
yeah i bought this on a similar
broker like quite light uh they're not
around anymore but it was a similar
broker uh not as flippa but it's uh it's
more of a broker and when you bought it
i was sort of like what the heck like
who does that i didn't even know anybody
who does like off these like random
websites
like i can see you buying something for
a few thousand dollars but 300 grand i
thought was a lot and i was like dog
ramps what the heck and you had told me
then
that uh you're like yeah the business is
doing good and the person really wasn't
doing any marketing or they didn't run
any facebook ads i think was the case
and so you just saw like a clear clear
growth level so break it down like what
is your
why do you do this and then how do you
do this buying businesses thing
yeah
um
like i me personally i think it's also
like what's your personal preference
what's your skill set some people are
really good at going from zero to one
are really builders
others are really good at going from one
to ten and those are you know scalars
uh i'm not really good at building
i'm better at
scaling and so i like to buy versus
build
because it gives you a lot more speed
it gives you history and data and it's
similar like real estate where i try to
find
um
crappy houses that you need to fix up
but in a good up and coming neighborhood
if that makes sense right right like you
know like okay
yes good market there's a market fit you
know if this house was amazing you would
be able to
rent this out for two three four times
more than the current uh owner does uh
it's the same with with website so i
look for websites that have a good
product mix uh product fit
um has history uh it doesn't have to be
you know going really well
i'm not looking for websites that are
overly optimized so i tend to not buy
websites from other internet marketers
uh because they already
did all the things that i probably would
do for it so it's not really room for
growth
so
i look for so what was the person
what was the person like or what was the
business like when you bought the dog
ramp business so describe kind of what
you saw and what made you decide yeah
i'm gonna buy this one
yeah um
it solved a real problem i i wasn't
aware that this is actually a problem um
i have a dog but i have a pit bull i
don't have a small dog
um
ben so there's a real problem for a
niche
audience that you really can target on
facebook those were the good old days
that you really could niche target still
on facebook um
it
had not a lot of competition at that
time not a lot of people were promoting
ramps on facebook instagram uh or even
amazon
the website was a very crappy
uh
website where i knew that if we switched
to shopify we'd
increase or improve the copy the
pictures etc the conversion rate would
most likely increase
um this case uh the two founders were
not doing any facebook ads there was no
paid acquisition happening at all
and even though they had a decent-sized
customer database they were not emailing
even existing customers let alone trying
to capture you know a card abandonment
uh so this was a good market which is
pets it's uh it's you know a house that
you said okay if i renovate the kitchens
the floorboards the the countertops
which is like redoing the website and
the branding of it the copywriting and
then lastly
they're not even trying to rent it out
they don't rent they don't post it on
craigslist they don't have flyers out in
the neighborhood saying come rent my
place which is they weren't doing paid
advertising uh
to get customers
so you saw it you bought it and you grew
it what's another example so let's walk
through um
let's walk through some real examples
and you tell me kind of like what you
like or dislike about some of these
businesses because i know you did some
research on on what's out there today
yeah um so for example there's one out
it's sort of a crossword puzzle website
so think of like when i think a lot of
people play these awards with friends
games or cross or scrabble games
um
and then there's a website out there
apparently that you can just put in your
letters and it will give a bunch of
awards recommendations
website yeah
exactly um and i kind of love it because
it's so there's no nothing to do like
you i think there's probably a database
that's already pre-built that you can
buy
you build it basically once um and then
it's just
trying to get seo traffic you know uh to
your website so for example there's one
for sell now for nine million dollars
they started it in 2017.
um does 3.5 million in revenue and
because there's no really team needed
it's like it's almost all profit it's
like three around three million dollars
of profit
and it's just you know printing money
basically um i like these type of niches
where
not a lot of people think about but
there's definitely a huge search volume
um
another one
what would you do so give me two two
pieces on that so the first is
um with something like this would you
how would you try to grow it or would
you would you not buy this because you
say i don't know how i would grow this
where
you know i get i get a faster payback on
my money so what would you do how would
you think about the growth levers for
this one
yeah that's a good question um i will
personally not buy it at the moment
but
because the price tag typically i
only buy
you know things in a couple hundred
thousand dollar range uh not millions
um
the old what i would without knowing too
much of the current business model i
definitely would
try to increase rpms meaning how can we
squeeze more advertising dollars out of
the same traffic
they get like tens of millions of
visitors a month
um
and
i looked at a couple of similar websites
and i think there's a huge opportunity
by
uh
placing ads differently just to increase
um
rpm similar if you have an e-commerce
you want to increase conversion rates if
you have a content site you want to
increase rpms meaning
how to get more people to click on the
ads or
things like that
um
so i would do that secondly i would look
and do research like for sure if there's
a huge segment of people that love
scrabble what is this like what other
games do they like and maybe build a sub
uh sister website that does i don't know
like what's it called sudoku uh
or whatever um
so that's that's the two the two things
that i would
uh if i would buy this type of website
and and basically when you buy something
like this most people say i don't have
nine million dollars and i think when
you started doing this when you first
started looking at these websites you
also didn't have enough money to buy one
of these so tell tell the story of like
how you first started going to these
websites even when you didn't have
enough money to buy buy one of these
companies
yeah
like i've actually
bought and sold
uh websites that started with buying
something for 500 and then sold it for
you know 1500 i started on flippa 12
years ago um and you know i've bought an
pinata website that sells uh pinatas you
can send a picture
uh of sam and uh it makes a pinata of
him
yes a company in mexi in texas texas
would make a piano and then ship it
directly to the customer so i bought
that uh for five thousand dollars that i
scraped together um
improved the website traffic and uh made
my money back in two and a half months
and then sold it a month later for 22
right so it's not huge numbers but those
really you know helped me to grow
a little bit and really get a lot of
experience
um
then um
when i started soap up
um i actually saw a similar website for
sale on flippa that was for sell for a
hundred thousand dollars was in the
daytime
uh tv uh
era too
and uh the topic was about
daytime tv of course i didn't have money
i had like um
a couple of thousand dollars i was not
able to buy that
um but what i did is like hey let's
see if there's something there let's do
a small test build a fan page
uh see how the engagement goes and then
see really how
you know if there is something there and
then grow from there i guess we should
explain
you um
you created if people have listened to
episode two they know the full story uh
we won't go the full story again this
time but
your claim to fame that what episode two
is about is telling the story of how you
created a
soap opera
um content site like a soap opera a
website that was basically just saying
hey you're watching days of our lives or
you're watching uh you know i don't know
the young and the restless um here's the
recap here's the spoilers of what's
coming next you kind of built like a
spoiler site for daytime soap operas
like who the heck thinks of that and
then you ended up selling it for nine or
ten million dollars cash and that's like
an amazing
amazing exit and this is from a guy who
has never watched a soap opera episode
in his life so i think people love that
because it was so a random but b
interesting and relatable how you did
that and it sounds like one of the ways
you were getting business ideas was you
were going on these websites and you i
think you told me at the time you're
like i saw a website for sale that was
also in the daytime tv niche that was
like a hundred thousand dollars for sale
and you're like cool like i don't have a
hundred thousand dollars but if this is
worth a hundred thousand dollars maybe i
could make something like this and then
you went through this process where
you said okay how can i test these ideas
because uh when i met you you i was like
all right what's your passion uh you
know silicon valley style and you were
like you know what problem you really
want to solve what topic what industry
really passionate about and you were
like there was a cup on the table i
remember we were drinking we were
drinking water a little paper cup we
were at this burrito place and you were
like
if uh if i could buy this cup for five
cents and sell it to you for seven cents
that's my passion like i like to buy
things and sell things for a little bit
more and i'm basically an internet
marketer and i don't care if it's cups
or dog ramps or soap opera spoilers it
doesn't matter to me i love the process
of like business and selling things and
i was like that's amazing uh you know i
love the the sort of self-awareness and
honesty and then when you were testing
ideas for for before you created the
soap opera site you went on facebook
and if i remember correctly you
basically made like 30 fan pages or
something like that because at the time
you could promote a page a fan page on
facebook for like cents you could go get
a bunch of likes of your facebook page
and likes weren't worth too much but you
could kind of test what topics are
people most
engaged with what what topics if i post
content in this page will i get a bunch
of likes for and i think it ended up
being like the top three were something
like what was it was like right wing
politics uh like soap operas and what
was the last one it was like
wrestling or something like that
yeah wrestling was really popular soap
opera was very
soaps and politics uh wrestling
and uh cars were also pretty pretty high
up right um and then you were like you
know i hate politics i don't want to do
politics what's the next best one soap
operas okay great uh hire this woman in
the midwest to write uh blogs every day
about soap operas and then drive traffic
baby uh selling yes to go sell some
paper cups
exactly and i just didn't really
overthink it i didn't wrote a business
plan i just like gone when on upwork.com
hey looking for a writer that can write
soap opera spoilers
put a very simple blog up just to test
to see
would people go from facebook onto a
blog and write the story and that's how
it basically started and then you know
started with 10 cents a day from making
from google adsense and then a dollar a
day and then 10 and that's how it grew
right okay let's look at a couple more
deals and then we'll we'll jump around
again so give me give me another one
that you saw before you came on the pod
that you want to talk about yeah so this
this is one i just saw uh an hour ago i
just thought it was interesting
interesting it was a goat milk soap
website itself
what the heck is that
yes so apparently uh goat milk soap is
better for the environment uh and it's
better for
they say it's cruelty free
because apparently a lot of soaps the
traditional soaps they do testing on
animals etc uh so they claim and like
forgive me for people that you know know
about goats milk soap i this is the
first time i heard about it and that's
why
i uh that intrigued me
um
but
it could probably be a product that
people that use this already passionate
about it seem like you know people that
are into keto are super passionate
or
you know there's tons of these examples
where it's a pretty small niche but
people are so passionate that they they
will spread the word for you
um so this is my website you can find it
on flippa um just search goat milk soap
it's it says
four years old monthly profit 20 000 a
month
uh it's got a 29 profit margin and it's
selling at a 1.8 x multiple right so
okay so what is that so let's say 20
times 12 we don't do public math but we
do type things in 240 240 times 1.8 so
it's selling for 400 something thousand
is that right
correct 400 425 is the asking price
right okay amazing so walk me through
how do you think about something like
this
yeah so first
um i look at
i will do a little bit research about
the product uh does goat milk really
work is it more of an uh more of a
gimmick or does it actually solve a
problem or are people really you know
interested is there a need for this
um
and again if it's a gimmick that's fine
too right i mean this is not like
oh the answer is no we'll not buy it uh
it's just important to know right back
to the
pinata example
exactly um
how many because
it's very important too for like not all
bit ideas have to be a hundred million
dollar idea like i think
um
a million dollar a year business is
amazing as well uh right so
uh maybe goat milk soap is you know um a
very passionate niche um
product uh i will look um i will do
research like okay how many people in
the us search for it uh you can use
google trends or you can use uh all
kinds of um search volume um trackers um
that you can see how many people are
searching for these keywords i will look
on instagram or they're like is there a
rabbit fan base you know like goat milk
you know
fans
or facebook groups
um then i'll also look on amazon
is this sold on amazon if yes
how is the trend and what is the sales
and then you can use a tool called
helium 10 to see
how many uh how much revenue a listing
is doing it's by the way really amazing
tool uh to do research i do the same for
pet products you know i look what is
trending on amazon
um what is you know blowing out the
waters for sales and then i will do
research if we should also start selling
that
um
then i look of course on the business
stuff like business um is the is the
trend up or down or flat
um and also like
most the business i
bought were either flat or down because
that's how you know you get you know a
good deal
uh so even if it's flat even if it's not
trending up i still would you know
potentially buy it
uh what is important are the traffic
channels diversified is 100 or 90 coming
from just facebook or is it just emails
or is it just
um seo that could be a little bit you
know risky uh especially if it's all
paid traffic from facebook uh because
all the e-commerce
founders or listeners uh on this podcast
will know you know
apple can make an update and suddenly
you know the paid uh
traffic landscape changed
so i'm looking for diversified channels
then of course i look at revenue profit
margins so you can really calculate like
okay if i pump
is this going to be more of a skill
where i can pump more money into
facebook i put a dollar in i get three
dollars back or is this more like a long
term play where i have to create seo
content
um
that you know is
less costly but it's a longer game
and then also what's important to
understand what you're buying
are the trademarks or the patents is
there email subscribers or in this case
they have a 43 000 email subscribers
there's 33 000 sms
subscribers
i think there's a social media all these
things um in my opinion are
valuable because that's the same with
when i bought alpha paw
they
had a huge instagram following the huge
facebook following they had an email
list
they had trademarks and patent all that
was you know
uh included in the sale
um
and if you those are great those are the
assets and so let's take a business like
this let's say it's 400 000 listing um
how does it work you know if you don't
have 400 grand lying around you know in
in a briefcase like a like a you know
evil evil genius what do you what do you
do how do you buy a business like this
if you don't have 400 grand lying around
yeah so
um
you can use
um sba loans uh to buy internet
businesses
um sba loan is basically a business loan
small business loan um that i don't know
when they started um
a few years ago where they now also fund
internet businesses
and you can
borrow up to 90
so technically you can buy something for
that is for sale for 400 000
and you only have to put down 40 000
um and the interest rate is is pretty
low it's anywhere between five and seven
so it's it's higher than a mortgage but
it's much lower than a traditional you
know a business loan um
for you know for people like us
um
then the second thing you can do when
you see the asking price of 400 000
um
you can
always
there's a cash upfront offer and then
you can offer like hey i will pay you
250 000
cash up front at closing
uh the remaining 150k
i will pay you spread out over the next
12 months interest-free
um so every time i buy business that's
never 100
hundred percent cash on closing i always
have
60 to 80 percent cash in closing and
remaining it's either seller's note or
an earn out
and that keeps the seller you know
helpful because they're you know they
need to help you out plus it lowers the
amount that you have to loan so let's
just say let's just do a little loan
calculator so sba loan is what 10-year
loan something like that
yes so 10-year loan so let's say you did
the full amount no seller financing just
for simplicity uh simplicity here so you
put down 40k
you're going to take the other 360 k as
a sba loan and let's say you're paying 6
a year for 10 years so your monthly
payment on that loan is gonna be four
thousand dollars
this business makes twenty thousand
dollars a month of profit so you take
the twenty thousand dollars a month of
profit you pay back your loan for four
you're left with 16k of profit every
month right now so you could buy this
today and be making money and so that
that difference let's say 16k you only
put down you know you only put down 40
000 so it only takes two and a half
months for you to get all your equity
back
and then you're p and you're profitable
every single month and you can reinvest
some of that into growth so that's like
a pretty s uh sweet deal and that's more
than most people are making at their
quote-unquote safe job
correct
and sba the beauty with sba loans they
of course they look at your personal
credit history and etc but they really
look and make a decision the the lenders
on the business so they will never fund
you if there's too high of a risk right
if they think like oh
if uh we cannot you know the the
borrower cannot pay the the interest
month over month um
so it's amazing too i actually spoke
with uh joe valley from quite light
broker
uh today and he told me story there was
a
a woman she bought a business for 1.25
million with an sba loan two years ago
and just closed and sold the same
business for 5.5 i believe it was in the
five range
um but put only 10 percent down so she
only she didn't even put 200k down
but her return was you know 4 million i
don't know
yeah um
so if done right you know sba loans is a
really great tool a good leverage tool
uh to get into internet businesses or
buy a business
amazing uh yeah it's this is one of the
tricks now uh what do you give people a
sense of how do you know make sure
you're not buying a lemon
yes
that's uh i get a question a lot um so
when you go to flippa.com i would really
um
be careful because flippa.com is a
marketplace anybody can just upload
you know their listing or their website
and basically claim whatever it's on you
to do the due diligence if you go to a
broker like white light brokers they
basically do all the vetting for you
they will like
look at the business is everything legit
um so the risk is much smaller
um but regardless if you're new to this
if you are you know it's your first
business you can
hire a due diligence company uh
centaurikai's synterica.com is one i
think those are the biggest uh
well-known
you pay you know it depends on the
listing price but it's as cheap as a
couple hundred dollars
um and it goes up from there but they do
all the due diligence for you they look
through all the traffic is it legit is
the revenue legit is whatever everything
they claimed is at all legit and then
they can come back to you with like well
we looked at all the data all the
numbers
um
you bought it for 1.2 but we think it's
actually worth 900k because these are
the reasons um so
definitely recommend going with a due
diligence company um like centurica
gotcha okay and give okay so these are
uh business you could buy what was the
first kind of like
how the heck did you become you right so
how are you figuring out how to do this
give people kind of the
uh not not you don't go deep into anyone
but just describe kind of the journey
and then i might poke into some that
sound interesting so
okay you're you're ramon you're born
and uh i don't know i don't know when
you got your entrepreneurial start what
was the first kind of like
entrepreneurial venture you were in your
teens or or 20s or what
my first real business was an
construction business um
i've done
things before that but were like nothing
really significant
um
but i think the way how i started the
construction company
is really
my dna that makes sense because if i
look back
a lot of other companies i started
basically the same i didn't know
anything about construction
um
and and uh the story um i will keep it
very uh quick but i think it's maybe
could be helpful for people that maybe
are overthinking steps or overthinking
things
um
so
i was out of job was 20 years old
had to pay my rent
um
co-worker of my mom said i need a
painter to paint the inside of my house
i can pay you x i forgot the number but
it was worth like a month's worth of
money that i made in three days so i
thought oh this is amazing i can you
know be my own boss it's a lot of money
the harder i work the more money i make
that was really what intrigued me right
like if i can do this in one day i will
actually you know have make the same
amount of money than in a whole month so
you got paid
not your input
correct
and um
and as you know like in my high school
dropout right so there was not uh
um
officially 15 but i stopped really going
when i was 14. um okay so that's
basically we got a letter right
that's u.s ninth grade i don't know what
it
my mom actually got a letter from the
board of school to with an official
waiver like okay your son doesn't have
to go to school because in holland you
have to go to school
mandatory to 16.
they actually gave me a pass because no
high school wanted to accept me
but that's a different story so that's a
bad guy
the
on sunday night she paid me out i said
this is amazing so on monday
morning
i
came up with a name
house improvements or home improvements
one of those two
um
build some uh design a couple very ugly
business cards made a one-page
uh website and put an ad out on the
dutch version of craigslist
and i thought you know what let's just
not do only painting let's do like we do
everything construction like remodeling
from a to z whatever
you don't know how to do any of that by
the way
no no i don't know anything i barely
said so so what gives you that
confidence to say i'll i'll renovate
everything a to z and yet i don't know
how to do anything a to z
i think that's the naive thing part of
me that i still have is like
let's just see first if i can get a job
and then figure out like how to solve or
do the job and
so an hour later or two hours later i
got an email
uh from a guy saying hey i'm looking for
an electrician
uh and um i am
rewiring the whole building blah blah i
said sure no problem
i'm a ninth grade dropout i'll be there
in three hours i got this
i went out to bought an official
construction outfit
um so i really looked like a
construction guy or like you know
um
and i went there the next morning
and um disclaimer of course i will not
have done things that will you know
potentially kill people
but i just wanted to see like you know i
don't know like maybe it was something
simple so he gave me
he gave me the tour and it was like he i
couldn't even understand the words he
was saying like oh we need to wire this
and we need to do and the floors were
open and the walls were open
and uh i was still playing along but in
my mind i was like and there's no way i
can do this plus it's dangerous as
um so he went out to run some errands i
waited for him um because i didn't want
to be like you know
an just go left so i waited for
an hour he came back and i was like
listen
i'm gonna be honest
i don't know about the construction
company i don't know about elektra
i
just started yesterday i want to build a
construction company but i don't know
anything
and he was because he was an
entrepreneur he laughed his ass off and
he actually gave me
work he said like you're hilarious um
just help me with you know getting carry
this box over here yeah
yeah
and he paid me the same amount of
dollars or euros uh hourly rate than uh
he would have done before
um
i think also by the way if we have young
listeners
i think it's so important to do those
things when you're young
because if i would do it now i'm 40
years old not endearing i don't think
it's not endearing it's not like oh i
appreciate your hustle no it's like hey
you're con man like yeah yes
so
if you're young take advantage you know
sam was also really genius of doing that
as well right like you can't just get
away with so much more of showing hustle
but also like i think he appreciated
that i waited for him and just be like
honest like hey listen i don't know
about this um but he gave me a really
good tip he said
in order to own a construction company
you don't have to know everything or do
yourself if i were you
find freelancers you focus on getting
the projects and then you outsource it
to freelancers so that's what i did
and found an electrician freelancer
plumber you know everything you need a
whole crew that you need
um and two weeks later i got a second
job
and i didn't do anything i just had my
you know
cruise assembly yeah
yeah i sold it for 10k my cut was like
around 5k
and that's how i basically grew the
construction company and within a year a
little over a year we were like at 20 to
24 people depending on how many projects
we had
um
and at that time we did close to a
million dollars or million euros sorry
um
a year
uh in revenue and you're like 19 20
years old something like that at that
time yeah 20
um
21 when we you know we're here in and so
what happened to that happy ending or
sad ending to the story
well very quick maybe story about how i
scaled
the scaling part i think that's also uh
maybe
could be helpful for people is that
um
the big problem with construction is
every like the job is two weeks and you
have to find another job their job is
four weeks they have to find another job
right so it was really hard to keep the
guys busy um
and really
you know make sure that um
the the projects align if that makes
sense so i thought hey
who can i find what can i do
so i don't have to find jobs anymore
so
real estate investors they buy
apartment buildings all at once they all
need to be renovated at once
so i went to um local real estate uh
meetups
um that was actually horrible because i
was a really out of my place i was way
too young i was like you know blue
collar guy
uh with all these fancy pens but one
thing lead to another that i met the
biggest uh
uh real estate investor
um
in
my region that i lived and he was like
literally built buying apartment
buildings at the foreclosure every month
between 20 and 100 buildings at the time
so now he became my client and he was my
client to the end basically i never had
to search for
a new uh customer
the so that was all the good news then i
made a bunch of mistakes uh cash flow
projection was one where construction
you really it's a similar a little bit
similar like with e-commerce i think
you could grow yourself into bankruptcy
if that makes sense
making
for example
you with a construction same with
e-commerce you have to put a lot of
money up front i have to pay every
friday the crew i have to buy the
supplies but i only get paid all the way
at the end when the project is done
so
the faster you grow the more projects
you have the more money
you have to put out in open and you have
to wait for it
so that started
um
that was really uh and i was just not
good at cash flow projections well i
just didn't do it
and
another thing that
really
was bad was
growing too fast that i have to hire
people that i normally would not have
hired um and
really lost grip of the business that
makes sense and you know it started to
break
and um
i had to close the company uh and after
three years more or less and our mutual
buddy silly was at my house this weekend
and he said something like uh i don't
know if maybe you already maybe this is
the guy you already talked about but he
said
he said you had some like mentor kind of
help you
early on uh somebody who really changed
the course of your life i i i don't know
is he talking about that guy that who
gave you that first kind of insight to
hire freelancers or is there somebody
else no he's talking about no this is a
different story
okay tell that one um
all right that story uh was before my
construction company
um
i was um
almost 18 or around that time
my mother kicked me out the house you
have to
you know live um
you have to figure your out so i
have to pay rent so i had to find a job
at a local
best buy um the the dutch version of
best buy
um
a couple weeks in i said like this sucks
right like uh long hours whatever and um
there was a guy came coming in in a nice
expensive suit
uh he wanted to buy something was not in
stock
he gave me a business card and said like
software solutions
um
and i didn't know anything about
software or programming or whatever but
i need more solutions because
poor solutions whatever i didn't know
anything
uh
but i just knew like okay hey there's a
lot of money to be made and a lot of
opportunity in because this was like the
early internet days right like you know
i'm an old right this is like
uh before 2001. uh before the internet
bubble as people remember um
and um
so i didn't know what he was doing but
it was something in software and
solutions and how you knew it was
good because he came in in a fancy suit
or you separately had been thinking
about the internet
uh separately been thinking about
because i always was like
trying to you know
um
oh let's buy
this type of product in germany and then
try to sell it in holland like i was
always trying to build these doing these
schemes
uh legal of course but um
internet was just like this whole new
like for me my like this was like
amazing like there's so many upper so
much opportunity um
and so i knew that i just didn't know
like exactly what how to get started
how to even you know write a line of
code or whatever
um so i started stalking him and said
hey
um and this is again the benefit of
being young
um
like hey i want to get a job at your
company
and he said no
uh we don't we're not hiring but i kept
stalking him respectfully but i did
caught stalking him for months like
three four months
to a point where he said
you know what
um
i'm so sick and tired of this in a good
way
um let's make a deal
if i'm gonna give you a book
on friday we have an internal exam for
programmers if you
uh pass that exam um i will give you i
will hire the company will hire you and
give you a six-month internal program to
become a microsoft uh developer
but you have to promise me if you fail
this exam on friday you have to leave me
alone for the rest of your life i said
okay let's do it
they know what it was expect he gave me
a book about microsoft database access
access database programming
um
study that if my life was depending on
it did exam and i passed uh i didn't
pass a plus but i passed enough and uh
so they gave me a job like gave me a job
um and for six the
next six months
they trained me i was able to become a
microsoft software developer
um
within this company they gave me
a lease card they gave me a laptop they
gave me like
phone like it was it was insane
yeah so this guy really changed my life
because i think
learning how to code uh really is
helpful also in other ways in in your
life like because it really um
you analyze problems
in situations just different if um
when when you know how to code that
makes sense and you but today you don't
consider yourself like a coder like
let's say for your your ecommerce
website you're not the one going and
making changes is do you do it like
sometimes or early on before you hire
people do you just do stuff yourself or
no you're just saying learning it back
then and
using it back then and learning how to
think that way was helpful
yeah and at the that time i had to learn
visual basic that language doesn't even
exist anymore
so it's like uh i know how to read php
and html and you know i know i know how
to do it but i'm like i never i never do
it
basically i i think it's more of
breaking down
what was so frustrating as a programmer
is like finding bugs so you have like
you know
a 10 000 line codes and there's one
thing bro
it breaks you have to go through like
all the codes but it really trains your
brain like okay how to
um
like
circle that circle down but like um
really try to narrow down what it could
be where the problem could be and that
mindset you can use in in all kinds of
other right you know real life
situations so i don't program right now
no okay fair enough and we got five
minutes left you had a game you wanted
to play at the end let's do let's do the
game
okay so i wanted to ask you
and why did you want to play this game
by the way
uh because i think
your audience would like to know these
questions like would you rather so it's
a root your mother let's give the people
what they want
yes
all right so here's the first one would
you rather be the ceo of apple or the
president of the
ufc oh
okay president of the ufc
like dana white uh
too much travel i'm traveling i'm on the
road all the time
dealing with with all kinds of head
event planning like when i threw my
wedding i was like this is the only
event i'll ever throw like this and uh
for the ufc every weekend they throw you
know a mega wedding so no way i'm doing
that
i also wouldn't really want to be the
ceo of apple so i'll take the job i'll
go buy your company for half a trillion
i'll buy my company for half a trillion
and then i'll peace out
all right
that's awesome
um i saw this on a meme actually
would you rather have dinner with jay-z
or take 500 000 cash
uh five hundred thousand dollars cash
easy uh what would you do would you take
dinner with jay-z i feel like you might
be a
i want a unique experience person no
yeah i will take the cash too there was
there was a whole debate uh like people
saying like you should take jay-z
because like let's say
i feel 50 000.
50 000 i think is a closer bet here
yeah
then i will in the situation right now i
will take the dinner um if i have no
money i will take the cash
right yeah yeah i'm in the same boat i
think the dinner is most likely going to
be kind of lame but you know i get a
good story who knows maybe maybe we hit
it off maybe he's interesting uh 500 000
that's
you could go buy your charity dinner
with jay-z for for 90 000 and have the
rest left over for goods after that
or you can buy a goat milk soap website
yeah exactly i mean
whatever that's the question would i
rather have that goat milk business
today or this dinner with jc
tomorrow i'll take the goat milk
business today thank you
yeah
um let's do would you rather
um
would you rather bootstrap bootstrap a
million dollar business or vc back 10
million a year business
um i think i would rather have a vc
backed 10 million your business i'll
tell you why i think that
once you can get a business to 10
million dollars i think the odds of you
being able to get it to 50 or 100 are
quite high i think 0 to 10 is a lot
harder or more likely to to
round down to zero
then 10 will stay at 10. so i think 10
million really what you're saying is hey
just stick with it for a little bit
longer and you'll be at 30 40 50
70 something like that million within
two three years so i think that's the
case and then i'm i'm actually a lot of
people think vc means you're vc forever
and that you're in this endless uh chase
they're like well the vcs say you need
to grow the vcs say you know you'll have
to raise your next round
my experience with vcs has actually been
quite different which is vcs give you
the money they might want you to do
something but it's your call what you do
and like you can raise one round and
never raise again from vc or you can
raise one round and grow at the pace you
want um they might strongly
advise you to do something but it's on
you to say look are you gonna fire me do
you have the power to do that are you
gonna fire me if not then i'm gonna need
you to you know shut the up and
stay in the back seat and like let me do
what i'm gonna do here so i think the 10
million business is just better than the
bootstrap to 1 million
then a very quick for the listeners that
have an idea but not the capital would
you tell them to
try to get vc
money or try to get
the company started uh get some revenue
and then do the vc route or
yeah i mean this is going to sound
cliche but it's true and whoever is
doing this needs to hear this which is
the
raising money is not the uh it's not the
goal like so a lot of people are like
hey i want to talk to you uh like i'll
invest in a company and they'll say i
want to talk to you about you know what
metrics we need to do to be able to
raise an a in nine months or you know
we're starting planning for our series b
i want to talk to you about what metrics
we need to do to hit the b
and i'm like
i understand what they're saying and
it's good to be thoughtful and plan
but there's this sort of implication
that
raising money is the milestone and it's
like oh what business what does this
business need to do to be able to
achieve this outcome and it's actually
the opposite it's i have a business
outcome i'm trying to get to i'm trying
to get to 10 million in revenue with 20
ebitda i'm trying to get uh 20 market
share in this market or 5
i want to grow 20 a month you have a
business outcome in mind and then you
just say do i need more money to make
that happen yes or no
um money is the fuel it is not the
destination it is not the it's not the
point of the journey uh uh for for
raising money and so i would just say
like yeah when you start when you have
the idea
uh the goal is okay well i need to get
like one customer 10 customers 100
customers a thousand customers you start
doing that and then at some point if you
get stuck because you lack the money
meaning you truly you need to go buy
inventory or your you paid ads are
working you just need to spend more to
get to the next milestone then you raise
the money don't raise don't raise as
your excuse to go do the business
yeah
and you also see a lot of uh deals or
people approaching you and you know me
in a little bit lesser way but i do feel
like there's a lot of people think they
need money to launch a business but
actually
don't
because they think oh it needs to be
pretty or it has to have all these
functionalities um
but maybe they could just like start
with one functionality and just have you
know a fiverr designer just do it and
you know do it at least get started yeah
my favorite people to
fund are people who have uh created a
company and like made all the mistakes
ended up with a small win where they got
a taste of winning but you know not not
not enough to go retire on a yacht
because the next time they start they're
like not going to waste those six months
on design mock-ups and branding and
getting the trademark and all this other
stuff like they know what are the traps
and they know what what you really need
to do versus what you think you need to
do and there's a big gap there but
usually even if somebody tells you
experience is the best teacher because
uh the voice in your head typically from
most entrepreneurs i meet the voice in
your head typically is giving you some
bad advice your first first time through
and it's okay like just go do it
learn those lessons and then the second
time you're much better off
yeah i agree
then last question would you rather do a
boxing match against sam or do an man
with me and suli
uh both i i'd rather do the boxing match
with sam because that sounds more fun
and exciting uh than like an endurance
race but uh yeah so i would do a boxing
match with sam i think that'd be great
you know
i've always wanted to like feel what
it's like to be
in a real fight like i think i got into
like one or two little altercations when
i was younger like in high school or
middle school but it was always like
i hit the kid and then he
he ran away or like he hit me and then
it got broken up and it's like it never
was like okay let's do this let's get
let's start no one's gonna break this up
and the point is to actually get in a
fight so i would do it although sam is
definitely like you know on horse
tranquilizers or whatever like horse
you know growth hormone or whatever he's
taking that guy's uh built like a
absolute monster right now so uh you
know i need a little training period but
i would do it
actually a lot of people because he's
been posting videos of me and him
sparring um you know he wants to become
an uh
uh fitness influencer now um
to his credit by the way he posts pic he
posts videos of you hitting him and him
going down normally when people post
they cherry pick what makes them look
good he does the opposite he posts up
you hitting him in the liver shots and
him falling down over and over again
like a compilation
yeah
and to be also to his credit he um he
started four or five months ago
um not super serious not that he's doing
it every day but he he actually got
really good really fast um you know i've
been training much longer um but a lot
of people on the twitter
comments actually
are voting for
uh you versus sam
so yeah maybe we should give us what
they need let's give the fans what they
want yeah we need we need like a
kickstarter or gofundme or something
it's like if uh if if certain number of
people
vote for this or buy the pre-buy a
pay-per-view five dollar pay-per-view of
this we'll do it we need like whatever
ten thousand pre-buys
okay ten thousand provides that's the
goal ten thousand pre-buys of a ten
dollar pay-per-view and then we'll do it
okay
let's set it up and then um
[Music]
you can give me like give me like i
don't know four months to train and
we'll fulfill the training yeah
four to six whatever each one can get
one uh good trainer boxing trainer uh do
you do what you're going to do boxing or
mma or no boxing is simple i don't have
time to learn five martial arts so
we'll get to the point where we're both
shitty at boxing and then we'll do it
yeah let's do it i think we should uh do
it and then maybe silly and i can box
too as though the free uh with that
yeah we should we should get anybody
it's a ceo boxing tournament
yes
and we stream it uh and we do it in a
really small ratchet like boxing gym
here so we can go there and then we'll
just stream it for for the people right
uh 10 000 free buys that's a lot but i
think it's doable uh especially if you
can get the support of your listeners
yeah we're saying it now uh people will
just have to see uh
we'll just have to get them a link and
let's get him a link and let's do it yes
all right
i can't wait all right perfect um okay i
gotta run i gotta do a call with this
guy ramon thanks for being on where
should people find you so now you're
twitter famous so is it ramon vanmir is
that your your twitter handle right
yeah ramone at ramon van meer all
together
ramon vanmir go buy if you have a small
dog like i have a maltipoo
uh i have four of your ramps in my house
because it's a lifesaver uh otherwise
your dogs get like you know injured
backs and they're jumping off couches
and stuff like that that's like imagine
jumping onto something or off of
something that's three times your height
right that's what they're doing and so
these ramps are onto the bed onto the
couch up the stairs you know that's how
i use them so go buy go buy some ramps
from alpha paw
[Music]
you